[Music]
there was an ad for Need for Speed on
the Super Bowl which I thought that was
really neat to get an ad for your movie
yeah Super Bowl you actually went to the
game right I did yeah my my wife and I
this is this is my fifth game in a row
her and I are third game in a row but uh
yeah I was great
and so we're worried like I'm just I've
never been to a Super Bowl I've never
been what kind of seat were you closer
to I was I was I was three rows behind
the Broncos bench on the 50-yard line
and it was so sad it was because you
were right it's why was your line there
and you know I'm not a I don't really
follow sports or NFL but I go to the
Super Bowl every year and I'm a die-hard
fan for whatever team I decided that I'm
gonna root for that year and it's like I
was born like a Broncos fan this year
just for that taste but that day that
day and I was screaming Peyton you can
do this I believe in you and I know he
could hear me I was three rows back yeah
well apparently you helped him out a lot
doing stops you're putting it's weird
pressure on me